do you know the secret to successfully
pitching an idea well is something kind
of unexpected it's fomo the fear of
missing out
as someone who invests in companies
early in their Journeys I listened to
nearly 2 000 pitches a year and I work
countless hours with company Founders to
help them make their pitch even more
compelling you may equate pitching with
a slick deck based on some standard
format but whether you're pitching a
company or trying to get buy-in for a
passion project that works so much of
pitching is a storytelling exercise you
need to bring people along with you you
need to tell your audience a story that
not only will draw them in but it will
make them feel that if they don't say
yes they will be missing out on
something really big
when people think about pitching they're
thinking inwards they think about their
nerves how smoothly they're talking or
what it takes to get to a yes but the
secret of successful pitching is to flip
it outward who are you pitching to what
do they care about how can you speak to
what motivates them for example if
you're pitching your startup idea to a
venture capitalist who has lots of money
to invest and needs big returns they
probably care about backing the next
Uber or doordash so you should focus
your story on the size of the market
opportunity if you're pitching to a
philanthropist or a non-profit their
motivation is likely about large social
impact so focus on showing how your
product or idea will improve things in a
lasting way if you're pitching a project
at work focus on the people you're
pitching the project to what do they
care about more Customer Loyalty more
revenue or perhaps a promotion tell them
how your project will help them attain
the goal that they want in a way that
makes it almost inevitable give them
that feeling of if I don't support this
I'm going to miss out on something I
care about deeply
pitching is much like telling a story
just like a movie Tells a Story You're
charting the hero's journey in three
acts first you start by telling about
the Hero's World the status quo in this
case the current situation that your
product idea or service will be
addressing then introduce tension and
conflict showing all the problems that
existing products aren't yet addressing
this will lead you to the big
confrontation you the hero Sweeping in
to save the day and from there give the
resolution how are things changed as a
result of your actions how does your
product idea or service solve the
problems you highlighted earlier one of
the best pitches I've heard follow this
art perfectly the story started with a
disturbing status quo depending on where
and how it's produced one gallon of milk
can take roughly a thousand gallons of
water to produce and can create about
six kilograms of CO2 equivalent or more
in the process in this case the hero was
the CEO and their team of scientists and
food industry experts who have come up
with a way to engineer plants to produce
animal proteins they showed how a small
crop of soybeans could create lots of
delicious cheese and how this could feed
the global population in a sustainable
and yummy way to anyone who cares about
both the environment and good food it
was an irresistible story it made me
feel like I needed to be part of it or I
would be missing out on a big
opportunity
when people are done charting their
hero's journey I make them identify
their biggest weakness is it that
they're missing somebody on their team
or that it's very competitive or that
they're trying to do something that has
never been done before most people's
instinct is to gloss over it or even
skip it all together but that's exactly
the wrong thing to do because the
audience will notice it and will ask you
about it instead face it directly tell
your audience hey you may think this is
a problem but here's exactly what I'm
gonna do about it and by showing the
strengths and weaknesses of your story
and not hiding anything you inspire
confidence not only in you but also in
your story the best storytellers they
live in the future and they come here
not to just tell us about it but to show
us the steps to get there and this makes
the audience lean forward and all they
need to do to be part of this amazing
story is say yes